it's time for seen and unseen where we
reveal the story behind the headlines
for that we turn to Fox News contributor
Raymond Royal Raymond I hear there was
some commotion at the White House this
week Jason we were covering the turkey
pardon for Fox and Friends which will be
airing tomorrow morning I'll be joining
them but when I left the White House we
encountered a group of pro Palestinian
protesters outside the White House they
were less than happy with the president
and his foreign policy
watch we want cease fire now we want to
stop this genocide what would you say to
those who say Hamas provoked this that's
absolutely LIE there's no evidence that
Hamas attack Israel killed their own
people absolutely the decision makers
like the pool in this office that
decides that it's okay to kill civilians
he's a war criminal himself if Hamas is
a terrorist organization then IDF is a
ter organization IDF is a bigger
terrorist organization if you ask me you
believe the Israeli retaliation to the
Hamas
attack let's not even talk about October
7th because what about October 8th
October 9 October 10 October 11 let's
keep going for over 6,000 children that
have been genocided massacred by our un
president here he's the one that's
funding Israel and backing them up and
giving them the green light to kill us
you know you know Jason you watch this I
and when I when I heard those folks and
you listen to the protests it is a
poisonous idea you know invoking history
whether real or imagined to justify
barbarity and then turn the tables and
say no you're practicing genocide here
well the Israelis didn't ask for you
know for their civilians women and
children to be slaughtered you know in
the morning uh unprovoked that's what
happened here and you see the this
reaction but they are angry and they're
angry at this
President yeah it's interesting to see
The Divide among the Democrats uh and
what's going on there but that that lady
she did not want to talk about October
7th that's for sure yeah no no they
that's what I'm saying they just dismiss
the barbarity and how about well didn't
Hamas start this and she said no it's a
lie oh okay the latest polling shows
that Biden's support among Arab
Americans by the way has fallen to 177%
that's a 42 percentage Point drop from
2020 now I talked to some of these
protesters about why they're turning on
the president and who they'll support
next time
watch did you vote for Joe Biden
unfortunately I did and I that was the
biggest mistake of my life will you vote
for him again never did you support
President Biden in the last election I
did and I will never never support did
you support President Biden in the last
election and will you support him not
now I will not support him last time yes
I did why not this I not I don't anyone
did you support president VI I did
unfortunately I did and are you going to
support him again hell
no hell no yeah look Jason as you know
better than I Virginia Michigan there
are key states where you have a a large
Arab population they are not happy with
this President and they may stay home
this time
out yeah I don't know that they have
anybody on their ballot except you know
Rashida T I guess is their hero but I I
don't know where they
go well and as the White House is losing
support with Arab Americans the
president seems more interested in
speaking to Americans that are too young
to
vote and by the way I like kids Better
Than
People and I love your ears I love them
they're really cool what's your name
Catherine Catherine what a beautiful
name that's my mommy's name well nice to
see how old are you
six you know Jason anytime he's around
children it's always awkward
uncomfortable and weird I mean who who
talks to children that
way I it's it's a little scary a little
spooky because there's so many videos
like that but Raymond I hear the
government is urging the public to be
cautious with their meal preparations
this Thanksgiving what are they telling
us well Jason they should have issued a
warning to those children uh about Biden
coming close but the US consumer product
safety commission issued their annual
Public Service Announcement about the
dangers of frying a turkey this time
they said it to
music
well you know Jason look it's here's the
reality uh these accidents of Home Fires
kitchen fires they rise three times
during the holid three times as much
during this holiday season that's mostly
doe to these friers so beware keep your
eyes on those friers and don't overfill
them ladies and gentlemen Happy
Thanksgiving hope it
safe good Thanksgiving to you as well
Raymond hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else